the 3200 tech companies at CES there is
a lot to see and thankfully Global Tech
PR expert Sarah Evans has sorted through
them to bring us some of the coolest
gadgets welcome to the show thank you so
much for having me it's always great
having you here what did you bring to us
from CES well let me tell you I clocked
at least five miles yesterday
there's so much to see but I wanted to
bring practical things that we could use
not all of these are to Market but we're
going to walk through one that is not
the big sexy topic natural gas I didn't
realize in your home that you need three
things to be safe fire Co and natural
gas I never knew this okay I didn't
either and this was the first
residential fire alarm ever invented in
1964 but now they're coming out with a
new product that they announced at CES
that's going to have a 10-year battery
powered alarm and it is not a plug-in
the plug-ins that you put in your home
actually don't detect gas that rises oh
my gosh and this is it right here it's a
small little thing you want this in your
home absolutely the really fun thing to
Mayor Goodman they championed the cause
to make today natural gas station the
awareness day in Las Vegas that's
perfect we have the product here on Las
Vegas now you are so dialed in I love it
Sarah what do you have next okay next
these are one of my favorite products
digital identity and wearable tech
batteries my phone dies like all the
time yeah I don't know about you these
don't need a battery they're NFC powered
so tap to touch so this is actually the
pet one and wouldn't you know it we
happen to have a furry we have a little
dog down here yeah with us today so
we'll just show you
you're a good girl
um so you actually put these on if
someone found your dog or your cat or
any animal that runs away somebody just
Taps their phone to this tag and will
pull up your information they don't need
anything downloaded no other
um soft you don't have to have if God
forbid you lose your pet yes and someone
sees this they tap their phone on it
they don't have to have the app
downloaded to get the contact
information right and it's not just for
pets there's wearable for humans let's
say you're a runner Avid Outdoors person
you fall you get hurt and someone sees
this band they tap that your emergency
contact information any family member
yeah as well these are allergies
anything it's like a you know wearable
medical bracelet that is fantastic it is
awesome it retails for like the 25 to 34
dollar range on their website where life
key two for two on stuff that everyone
watching can use absolutely I'm excited
about it okay I'm so excited about this
thing I kept it for number three because
I really wanted to keep everyone super
interested do you know anyone who snores
because I do and I'm not calling you out
dad but it's it's for you everyone knows
someone that's North I'm the snoring in
the relationship okay so this pillow
gets smarter as you sleep it is powered
by AI technology you can see it's moving
up up and down it listens to your
snoring sounds and identifies when you
need to be moved it's moving yes it's
waiting and deflating but it's still an
actual pillow it doesn't feel like it's
comfortable so if I'm snoring normally
the routine is my wife nudges me says
you're snoring I gotta roll over so if
I'm snoring this thing will detect it
raise my head up roll me over so I stop
snorting side to side that is brilliant
at 93 of people who tested this improved
on their snoring when can we buy this
all right this may not be available
until Q3 and it's going to retail for
seven to eight hundred dollars so it is
a high price point item but it might be
ready for next holiday season but it's
gonna help with sleep though too because
you're not being woken up by night
you're not waking up your spouse invest
in your health is what this is all about
and it doesn't wake you up so you have
those big CPAP machines all of those
things this is something that's supposed
to inflate and deflate comfortably not
to wake you up the inventor is right
there I love this uh time for one more
should we do this right here absolutely
even though it's Holograms so you can
see it's happening right here in front
of us so let's say you want to talk to
Grandma and you usually do FaceTime yes
well this is going to make her feel like
she's in the room with you and actually
put her right there with you so let's
think about the person you're talking to
is in the room and you can interact with
him and feel like you have more human
connection which I think is really
important this is fantastic this may be
kind of a more big question but could
you if you lost a loved one could you
because you have to wait a Houston
Holograms and everything else yeah I
mean did you go a little further yes I
think this is how they started in fact
uh Paris Hilton said she was an advisor
and investor today and they have other
celebrities involved with this so it's
definitely something to keep an eye
because the same people evolved with the
whole Whitney Houston hologram show are
involved with this you can get that
technology in your home yes so Proto M
now again higher price point item we
started with some things that were a
little more affordable right I love it
so if you want to get something like
this it'll retail for around two
thousand dollars perfect so you can
check it out and see if it's something
that works for you thank you so much
there I gotta wrap it up real quick this
social media handle to get in touch with
you you can find me on Twitter PR Sarah
Evans are on Instagram it's Sarah Evans
thank you so much such helpful